بعد يوم واحد من تلك الاحتفالات التي أقيمت هنا
في وسط كييف لإحياء
الذكرى السنوية الأولى
للغزو الروسي وللاحتفال بحقيقة أن
كييف لم تكن قادرة على تحمل أي
علامة على الضربات على الصعيد الوطني التي
تعرض لها الكثير من المسؤولين الأوكرانيين.  وكان
المدنيون الأوكرانيون
يستعدون لهذه
الذكرى السنوية الأولى، بل منذ ذلك الحين،
اشتداد القتال
على طول خط المواجهة على
الجبهة الشرقية وتحديدًا الأخبار الواردة من باكموت
والتي وفقًا لما ذكره إيفجيني بريجو على
رأس مجموعة مرتزقة فاغنر  تلك
المجموعة التي كانت أساسية جدًا في توفير
المزيد من القوة البشرية حيث حاولت القوات الروسية
تطويق المدينة إذا كان هناك أي
ادعاء بأن قريتين مهمتين في
الشمال والشمال الغربي قد سقطتا الآن،
كما سمعنا من
الجانب الأوكراني على شكل
يقول القائد الأوكراني إن
محاولة المشاة السيطرة على هذه المدينة ستكون ذات
أهمية رمزية كبيرة كمكسب
لروسيا ولكن أيضًا من الناحية الاستراتيجية لأنها
تسعى إلى تحقيق هدفها المتمثل في محاولة الاستيلاء
على منطقة دونباس بأكملها،
وأوضح القائد الأوكراني أن المشاة
هناك  نفاد ما
يحتاجون إليه لمحاولة الحفاظ على خطهم، ويفتقرون على
وجه التحديد إلى الطائرات والدبابات
والمدفعية طويلة المدى، هذا مع
استمرار الحلفاء الغربيين في التعهد بمزيد من الدعم
لأوكرانيا. يواصل الأوكرانيون القول
إنهم بحاجة إلى مزيد من المساعدة إذا كانوا
سيصمدون بثبات.  الصالة الرياضية الأجنبية